I have to give you an update about the
continuing back and forth over
intellectual property theft from Sam
cedar some really really ugly
allegations have now surfaced in the
midst of this that my family allegedly
ran to Argentina as Nazis to seek safe
haven in the time after World War two so
this has really taken an ugly turn first
it was all about my supposed
intellectual property theft of sam
cedars set design then on april 1st
which is irrelevant dates we escalated
by allegedly stealing the design of
sam's logo that is over his left
shoulder during the program and then
also on April 1st relevant again that it
was all on April 1st we published a clip
to our YouTube channel where I mimicked
a Sam cedar segment where he pranked one
of those IRS scammers i pranked one of
those IRS scammers so it's gotten very
very ugly and this caller to Sam's show
Ronald Reagan called into Sam's program
and made the extraordinarily ugly
assertion that my family's presence in
Argentina may have been linked to Nazism
take a listen to this just kind of like
unrelated I found out over the weekend
that David Pakman was born in Argentina
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I thought that's weird what kind of
name is pac-man right pac-man pac-man so
do a little research pacman it turns out
is the German name wrong so you know
German born and I'd heard that pac-man
is Jewish so are you actually suggesting
in addition to a very disturbing
familial history some stolen valor here
well I just like you know it's bad
enough that we have to worry about
intellectual property theft but now we
have questions about all right
extremely ugly allegations Pakman is not
a German name it's a Russian Ukrainian
name and I want to be super clear my
family went to Argentina before the
Holocaust my family is Jewish this is a
horrible horrible smear and in fact my
great-uncle was one of the Mossad
operatives involved in kidnapping Adolf
Eichmann from Argentina okay that last
thing wasn't true but I'm just trying to
trigger Ronald Reagan into looking into
more of this stuff I you know this
really is getting very very ugly and I
hope that it stops
as I've mentioned I've retained Marky
Geragos to represent me in this entire
thing and we are going to be
countersuing both Sam and Ronald Reagan
for defamation and punitive damages and
it's going to get very very very ugly
and I look forward to a chatting with
Sam about it in person over dinner next
week in Las Vegas even though it's
gotten extraordinarily ugly between the
two of us